it's where I'm recording oh did I just
zoom in look at that wow wow run run toe
tiny now I love you yeah G didn't have a
huge ego before I'm good that was a
terrible story I'm very upset and I
apologize to you guys
what's up everyone happy weekend so once
I once a quarter I do a thing where I
pay for all of my tds team it's
instructors and helpers some people
coming tonight 2222 pay for 22 people to
go to a salsa cruise so we're going to
go to Lake Ontario I want to go dancing
and I was told to dress to impress so of
course I'm rocking the gear he has in a
tread white dress with her new purple
hair have you guys check that out
cooking video que tous Nina's first solo
video any we're gonna hop in the car
drive downtown get on the boat meet our
trauma that salsa friends and have a
night of dancing
we made it tightness we r we going this
way this way so we're heading to find
our boat and Alex and the team so down
this street is what I'm doing my audio
book this is really in the middle of
nowhere where I oh can she see entirely
good i see entire behind us huh look at
that it's really a middle of nowhere and
super random that where i'm filling my
other book is like a block away from
over on the boat so i'll be back here on
Monday feeling more audio book for you
guys who's this hey we parked on this
street see you there that's cat and
Philippe our key Zumba instructors in
salsa inspectors and training so let's
cross this beautiful lady right here I'm
determined not to turn into roadkill
ready ready run run don't die Nina I
love you oh look at the city behind look
at that huh yeah it's rato toronto aunt
city stepping up okay let's turn this
off in time where we're going
I'm warming up I'm warming up there's a
lot of wiggling happening there there we
go Alex story time with Alex I upgrade
my phone every two years so before this
added a note for so I waited past the
note 5 was a note 6 but they called him
notes out anyways I waited for this
phone for two years then I had a whole
like life-changing experience about not
being attached to like not important
things like phones and stuff like that
Nina's on her phone of course because I
know this story I go into Roger store
and I'm like hey you know what here's a
free phone with two year contract
instead of paying six hundred dollars
for the note 7 when it came out I'm like
I'm gonna compromise and get the phone
so I go and I get the phone but I find
out that it doesn't have an SD cards
like 32 gigabyte that's all I have and
for a snapchat and all the stuff the
phone the phone is not gonna be enough
so I run back into the storage I signed
a contract I open the phone and I'm like
I beg them on my knees almost I please
let me return this phone so fine we get
return the phone and i get i get sucked
in and i end up getting the note 7 which
was depressing for me because i was like
trying to let go of being attached to
like not important things that's like
six hundred dollars because i work here
it's not working out great and the phone
is getting recalled the phone that i
waited a year for that I tried to get a
floating phone the explode the milk or
the phone exploding phone funny enough I
drop that phone I've never dropped the
phone in my life like I've dropped it
but never never cracked it four days ago
i dropped the phone where i was at a
wedding and it fell and cracked the skin
crack and I'm like oh my God thank God I
can return it still right because it's a
recall they should be able to accept it
so I going to the Roger store and I'm
like hey guys I want to return this
phone i wanna get another phone and like
we can't take this back phone the phone
is cracked and I'm like my face goes
pale because I'm like my fiancée is
gonna kill me first of all because it's
like we just spent six hundred dollars
on this phone ridiculous thing that I
can't return you know what they gave me
a gradient said listen Carl Rogers talk
to them explain to the situation if they
can okay it we're happy to help you and
these are the guys that helped me
previously switched phone so that I had
a really good rapport with them really
cool guys the right next to empress walk
so i called garage I'm like listen I
explained the situation I feel so bad i
was looking forward to this phone
and got a question nothing like no
problem we'll make the notes boom boom
boom so in a week's time I'm gonna go
return my phone and I'm getting a Google
pixel Excel phone which I'm gonna get
for free just get one plus three no 1 +
38 it's better than 1 i'm gonna i'm
better than your no 70 no no so cut no
okay wait all right hey cover some
what's the lesson from this story i
filming for 3 minutes it better be
awesome lesson at the end of this focus
on important things and not things like
phones and get obsessed about it because
once you have it you're not gonna really
care about it that was a terrible story
I'm very upset and I apologize to you
guys we look kratika we love you Alex
but come on man all right here we go
thanks a modern very fancy what's your
message to the world fay all my message
keep on dancing keep on dates a good one
keep on dancing thing ok we're going to
do story time with Alex number wow sorry
time with Alex number two well stake
this one is better and I hope you guys
hear it i was performing with the town
isn't performance team teacher team on
sunday i have a salsa congress
and I was social magazine ah Friday
night and so this room approached me
asked you to that Mackenzie I love you
guys would be perfect we're dancing
laughing having a great time we're
walking off the desk phone she's like
thank you Alex and I'm like Alex I'm
like in my mind I didn't reduce myself
right maybe she's a suitor of mine I
like okay who I'm like how did he know
Joe's I'm sorry and she's like I know
you come online from
I want more I want more people make
better videos we decided to come outside
to get some air and look in there
Toronto and city the Blue Jays they play
there I'm invading the personal
conversation between Lily Alex and
Philippe about confidence although he
wasn't sure oh hello so busy kind of
confident this is very good
okay good it is a family channel
Philippe family channel is your copy the
Daleks I was raised differently what's
up on doing what's the female equivalent
we're wearing one covering everything is
confidence actually talking me how we
met Philippe like how that was happened
apparently first met me I Dan up Tomas I
was performing with the sauce Chandra
and he was watching move I'm known for
my eyebrows being raised without
performing such as was a selected and he
saw my reference i was very arrogant
mizzle and overly confident in myself is
that a huge ego yeah she did have a huge
ego before good
all right Alex wants to do a group
picture I think I was cold get everybody
here so that I did my job this is
everybody I see five people TDS team
that's it that's my crew we have a
special announcement we have a helper of
the semester this person rushed it as a
helper during the summer 2016 has so
much positive feedback everyone loves
this guy Oh Bob blown away I can't
believe you guys are doing this wow wow
I love to get so much honestly this
place is commuted family it's just it's
really amazing I love being a part of it
I love giving back yeah all right we're
back on dry lane 1 something in the
morning we had some dances we had some
fun I'm gonna find Alex for a final
message final message message whatever
you do make sure you spend them with
your loved ones with your family with
your friends because it's all about the
experience and not what you do final
message what's the final message resign
as final messages you can do it lily and
face final message is live downtown
Oakland you can walk home oh so sad so
moving to the country doesn't matter
where you live in a balm is way below
their yeah we're tired it's time to go
home
we get in the car have an amazing rest
of the weekend guys thank you for
joining us on our fun excursion today
hope you had a great weekend to continue
to believe or whatever your one word is
I will see you soon